[Musique]
océan lac et rivière forêt et jungle
plein désert
la vie existe partout sur la terre 8
millions d'espèces animales et végétales
y vivent mais une seule d'entre elles en
fait disparaître d'autres et ce de plus
en plus vite
chaque année cette espèce est homo
sapiens
un tiers de la flore et de la faune du
monde ne peut disparaître dans les
années à venir
il n'en restera plus que des légendes ce
n'est pas une exagération mais une
prédiction scientifique
ce film parle de ses prédictions
déprimante et de ses vies que quelques
humains tentent de sauver
[Musique]
l'apparence de notre planète a
radicalement changé à plusieurs reprises
à cause de catastrophe deux périodes
glaciaires de l'apparition de nouveaux
types d'animaux et plantes 99 % des
espèces ayant habité notre planète ont
disparu les scientifiques estiment qu'il
y a déjà eu cinq extinctions de masse au
cours de l'histoire mais la 6e ne
ressemble en rien aux précédentes
pékin ce n'est pas vraiment l'extinction
la plus massive
il ya eu celle qui a balayé les
dinosaures de la surface du monde à
cette époque là tu 70 % des espèces sont
mortes par est le problème de
l'extinction massive en cours et que
nous sommes nous mêmes impliqués donc
nous pouvons nous effacer nous mêmes
c'est différent du cas des dinosaures
ressort il s'agit d'un nouveau chapitre
de l'histoire les humains affectant la
planète de manière drastique les
scientifiques parlent de l'ère de
l'anthropocène plus il y as d'humains
plus vite disparaissent et les autres
habitants de notre planète
l'un des plus ancien mammifère de la
terre et la baleine grise
el bez jusqu'à 30 tonnes pour 12 m de
long cette espèce à 10 millions d'années
coloré en brun noir ou en gris brun les
baleines vivait 60 à 70 ans est un peu
comme les humains elle avait des
empreintes individuelles qui prenait la
forme de taches grises propres à chaque
animal il fut un temps où des dizaines
de milliers de baleines grises vivaient
dans les océans
[Musique]
la chasse à la baleine était brutal été
chassé pour leurs énormes réserves de
graisse cette graisse était utilisée
pour l'éclairage et pour d'autres
raisons techniques
à cause de cette chasse la population
atlantique a été presque complètement
exterminer pour leur graisse leur viande
et leur fanon les humains se sont mises
à chasser ces mammifères qui pendant des
centaines d'années
on habitait les océans du nord les
baleines qui vivait près du japon et des
îles kouriles ont été éradiqués aux
xviiie et à la fin du 19e siècle
j'ai rencontré des baleiniers coréen la
casa aussi surnommés ces baleines les
baleines fantômes étaient privés general
motors etiquetté place qu'elle
apparaissait pendant les brouillards
printanier était vraiment difficile à
trouver
antully une était considéré comme un
grand exploit
les baleiniers coréen adoré les chasser
on en a vu pour la dernière fois au
large des côtes coréennes au début des
années 1960
peu de temps après la baleine grise
étaient ajoutés à la liste des animaux
disparus
mais lors de l'été 1984 des
scientifiques soviétiques ont repéré
quelques baleines grises près de l'île
de sakhaline lors d'un vol d'observation
on a dépensé la population de baleines
grises du pacifique ouest complètement
éradiqués par la chasse à la baleine en
permanence par mais il s'avère que
quelques dizaines de survivants ont été
repérés cette équipe bien sûr une fois
que ces animaux ont été découverts ils
ont été ajoutés au livre rouge de la
russie et à la liste de l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature avec le statut le plus élevé
les humains ont maintenant une chance de
prouver qu'ils peuvent sauver au moins
certaines des espèces avec lesquels il
partage la planète
[Musique]
longue de presque 1000 km sakhaline est
la plus grande île de l'extrême orient
russe
[Musique]
au nord se trouve le village de negra
sauf qu'à la colonie la plus éloignée de
lille l'école locale à une tradition des
cours annuel de sciences de la nature
pour les élèves de tous les âges
bonjour erwin kalinin qui dirige les
projets écologiques de sakhaline donne
un cours savez-vous en quoi les baleines
grises diffère des autres baleines quand
quelqu'un a une idée il y en a peu il
faut oui c'est juste mais c'est ainsi
pour toutes les baleines à eycheil quoi
d'autre leur façon de se nourrir juste
les baleines grises diffère des autres
baleines dans leur façon de se nourrir à
elle filtre les fonds marins boue près
de la côte et mangent chaque jour
jusqu'à une tonne de mollusques
crustacés ver marin et poissons de fond
elle adore sakhaline car elles peuvent y
trouver rapidement beaucoup de bonne
nourriture
si vous regardez leur habitat historique
elles ont habité dans les eaux autour de
la corée du japon près de la côte
asiatique de la mer du japon
[Applaudissements]
andrei ce matin et le chef du
département de protection de
l'environnement d'une société pétrolière
et gazière
il va de ioujno sakhalinsk à l'extrême
nord de l'île
de nombreuses entreprises ont des
infrastructures pour la production de
pétrole et de gaz en mer au large de la
côte de sakhaline il ya cette idée
profondément enracinée et non sans
fondement que le pétrole et le gaz sont
l'une des pires industrie pour
l'environnement pour cette raison des
autorités réglementaires et le public et
pas seulement le public russe le public
mondial ont exprimé leur préoccupation
s'ils ont exigé que l'exploitation des
plateaux continentaux soit menée de
manière à ne pas menacer l'environnement
le financement de l'industrie pétrolière
et gazière de la côte de sakhaline a
commencé à la fin du xxème siècle et
était directement lié aux activités
sociales et écologiques des entreprises
toutes surveillées par la communauté
mondiale de conservation de la nature
pensons constance à l'union
internationale pour la conservation de
la nature à créer un groupe consultatif
sur la baleine grise
nous n'avions jamais rien eu de tel
auparavant tueur cela permet de
rassembler dans le monde entier les
meilleurs spécialistes des baleines
scarna du canada d'amérique et ou de
russie une clause spéciale a été incluse
dans les contrats de prêts entre banques
et opérateurs toi campagne pratique chez
elles les entreprises doivent en forme
et ce panel de leur plan de forage avant
de mettre en oeuvre de nouveaux projets
à travers la cnac et chair et en os à y
être
sayad beau temps d'aller le panel
analysera l'impact et donnera aux
entreprises des recommandations pour le
minimiser comme aide à ces points
muezzin cela existait
pour la première fois dans l'histoire
des entreprises vont exercer leur
activité en tenant vraiment compte des
facteurs environnementaux les sociétés
pétrolières et gazières ne sont alors
plus d ennemis mais des amis de la
nature et des baleines grises en
particulier c'est très délicat car il ya
du pétrole et du gaz à proximité de leur
habitat nous faisons des efforts pour
essayer de les protéger au cours de
l'exploitation pétrolière et gazière
dans la région ce qui unit qu'ici à
sakhaline
c'est que non seulement il s'agit d'une
population de baleines menacée mais leur
zone d'habitation est aussi très très
restreinte
c'est pourquoi nous devons protéger
cette population
la baleine grise du pacifique ouest est
considéré comme étant au bord de
l'extinction
mais a maintenant une chance de survivre
diverses compagnies pétrolières et
gazières opérant dans la région ont
lancé des expéditions presque
simultanées pour étudier les baleines
grises
je vais aller voir comment ça se passe
car d'après les conversations
téléphoniques il ya un grand nombre de
mères avec des petits là bas on s'attend
à un taux de fécondité élevée cette
année le wwf russie surveillent le
programme des deux entreprises pour la
baleine grise de sakhaline
les écologistes reconnaissent maintenant
que la collaboration de longue date
entre les entreprises et la science pami
les baleines hors de danger immédiat
on ne peut pas en dire autant de tout la
vie animale et végétale sur terre
l'impact humain sur notre planète se
constate tous les jours mais très peu de
gens en assume la responsabilité
demander qui a renversé le lait ou
casser la tasse que ce soit un chat un
scientifique ou un enfant chacun dira ce
n'est pas moi personne ne veut admettre
la faute de l'homme dans le cas du
changement climatique
nous essayons de le nier les baleines
grises au large des côtes de sakhaline
sont surveillés en permanence depuis
la première tâche des scientifiques a
été de repérer le dos ou la nageoire
d'une baleine grise de tenter de la
photographier et d'enregistrer l'animal
dans une base de données car dans le
monde
en attendant creuser notre collaboration
pour la protection des baleines grises
rend les employés de l'industrie
pétrolière chaque année un peu plus fier
du fait qu'ils peuvent opérer sans nuire
à ces animaux je vois à et en richesse
kadhafi je vous tiens à dire que
certaines des recherches scientifiques
financés par ces programmes nous ont
apporté des informations uniques sur ces
animaux
ce meeting à bâtir un projet conjoint
russo américain de surveillance par
satellite a permis de marquer les
baleines avec des balises et de suivre
leur itinéraire
en automne des baleines aperçues près de
sakhaline ont migré vers l'est
traversant la mer d'okhotsk autour de la
cam chaque cas puis la mer de béring
pour se diriger vers la côte ouest
américaine vers la californie et le
mexique
les tl ont suivi la même route pour
retourner sur la côte de sakhaline les
baleines mix sur environ 22 mille
kilomètres en un an ce qui représente
presque la moitié du globe vie souvent
dans un espace qui se résume à un ou
deux quartiers où se trouve l'école les
magasins les supermarchés tout ce dont
il a besoin mais l'espace des baleines
c'est la moitié du globe
elles viennent se nourrir sur les rives
de sakhaline puis s'en vont hiberner sur
les côtes de californie où naissent leur
petit fils et femelles reviennent à
sakhaline avec eux et un nouveau cycle
recommence c'est fascinant
après la découverte de la route
migratoire des baleines grises
ce qui n'était qu'un projet local de
sakhaline devient une affaire mondiale
chaque année nos baleines se rendent en
amérique ça a été une révélation et une
découverte pour tout le monde c'était
quelque chose de positif de très
intéressant un autre groupe de baleines
s'avérer très inhabituel nos programmes
sur les baleines grises sont
intéressants pour les enfants car il
découvre qu'il existe de nombreux
endroits riches et variées sous l'eau et
ne ressemble pas à ce que nous avons sur
terre il le met dans l'eau le tiennent
parfois le caresser le mas de sorte que
le dauphin sentent que les humains ne
sont pas ses ennemis et qu'il est dans
son environnement naturel
nuit des baleines est une fête annuelle
de sakhaline elle a lieu en septembre à
l'occasion du world maritime d'air les
visiteurs viennent se familiariser avec
les mammifères marins vivent près de
lille l'otarie de steller l'orc est bien
sûr la mystérieuse baleines grises un
jour disparu avant de réapparaître comme
dans un vrai conte de fées animalier
lula
les habitants autochtones du village
donné grâce au fca sont les nivkhs les
insulaires n'ont jamais chasser les
baleines grises mais partagent des
légendes évoquant deux grands animaux
marins que l'on pouvait observer depuis
la côte est qui était pour les naïfs que
l'esprit de la mer pendant leurs cours à
l'école de nekrasov cas les élèves ont
donné des surnoms aux baleines grises
pour aider les scientifiques la
population de baleines augmente et les
nouveaux arrivants nous besoin d'être
distingué par autre chose que des
chiffres
vous vous souvenez du concours que nous
avons organisé l'année dernière pour
trouver des surnoms aux baleines vous
avez donné des surnoms aux baleines quel
surnom leur avez vous donné et j'ai
donné à ma baleine le surnom de piquant
ce qui veut dire gigantesque en ift j'ai
appelé la mienne tôt lisent ce qui veut
dire mètres de la mer j'ai appelé ma
baleine niche car ça veut dire coeur
certains
une fois nous sommes allés prendre des
photos d'une baleine que nous
connaissions déjà la des fins
d'identification son surnom était ami
car elle était très sympathique
ensuite nous nous sommes arrêtés pour
prendre des notes
cette baleine est revenu et a décidé de
nous asperger du coup on l'a renommé
endorphines hormones du bonheur
après une nuit dans le train nous avons
pris une voiture nous sommes dirigés
vers la baie de piles thoune une fois là
bas nous essaierons d'atteindre la
neuvième station à l'embouchure de la
baie où il observer le travail des
spécialistes là bas
[Musique]
en juin les baleines nagent jusqu'aux
côtes de sakhaline pour se nourrir et y
est resté jusqu'en octobre
là il y a une bonne dizaine de ces beaux
animaux
il est difficile de savoir où chercher
les scientifiques étudient le nombre le
comportement et le régime alimentaire
des baleines et plus important encore la
façon dont le bruit les affectent par
exemple celui des navires de passage ou
de la fracturation hydraulique
quand je vous rendrai salut salut
comment ça va bien
le voyage s'est bien passé très bien
nous sommes arrivés ici sans aucun
problème
nous pouvons prendre un train maintenant
et là où tu étouffes génial content
d'entendre ça alors pendant que tu
prenais des bains de soleil d'accord
alors pas besoin de revenir en arrière
et café allons-y oui on y va de nombreux
scientifiques travaillent par roulement
à ces postes d'observation mais le
hollandais pieter van der wolf est tombé
amoureux de l'île de sa nature en
particulier des baleines grises et a
décidé de s'installer sur sakhaline à il
vit ici depuis 15 ans et se débrouille
bien en russe donc le vent et dans ce
sens là bien
un peu comme sa partie gagnée on y va
[Musique]
excellent les méthodes de surveillance
ont progressé depuis les années 1990
maintenant les baleines sont surveillés
depuis treize postes d'observation qui
couvre 100 km de la côte de sakhaline
la méthode la plus sûre et la plus
pointue est la surveillance par drones
l'essentiel est de ne pas effrayer les
baleines en volant trop près d'elle
[Musique]
nous avons de la chance un par les orcs
une baleine arrive ici c'est fantastique
quant à elle est là il n'y a pas de
nounou pour s'occuper d'elle comme
d'habitude spitz avait surtout les
nounous sont probablement plus loin en
mer là il y en avait quelques-uns on a
nous avons une baleine nous nous ici
nommé en types en trip
elle est très très grande et plutôt
blanche
elle prend toujours trop quatre petits
pour s'en occuper a laissé ils nagent
toujours sous zèle sur moi par an sergei
a dit qu'en type était un prénom
masculin c'est juste oui c'est masculin
masculin eh bien il se trouve que c'est
une nounou aussi je pense que c'est une
baleine qui a dépassé l'âge de procréer
donc elle élève ses petits neveux oui
bien sûr la famille est grande
quelqu'un doit oui quelqu'un chez les
adultes doit prendre soin des enfants
pendant que leurs mères mange
oui ces observations ne sont qu'un début
des travaux sont en cours dans des
centres des deux côtés du pacifique
les scientifiques comptent un album
photo de chaque baleines qui visitent
sakhaline
il le met à jour chaque année et
connaissent chacun de ces grilles
visiteurs les dernières données
indiquent qu'il y à 2 197 individus
mais
alors que se passe-t-il de manière
générale nous avons dix neuf couples
mère baleineau combien 19 à temps on m'a
dit 17
on en a trouvé deux de plus oui de
encore oui et ils étaient avec leur mère
c'est que ici nous avons un record
historique
après avoir vérifié les postes
d'observation andres à madoff s'envole
vers la plateforme gazière lukaya à
l'une des nombreuses plateformes près de
sakhaline
elle produit jusqu'à 48 millions de
mètres cubes de gaz par jour ce qui
représente l'essentiel de la production
du projet sakhaline-2 travaillant pour
l'entreprise
andrei est remplie ici également le
devoir d'inspecteurs il doit passer en
revue toutes ces activités il connaît
bien le cahier des charges et doit
s'assurer personnellement que toutes les
normes écologiques sont respectées
lagence des ressources naturelles a de
nouveau confirmé que fauré avec notre
technologie optimisée ne nuisent pas à
l'environnement
respectons donc ces normes
les déchets du forage sont tombés dans
un réservoir de sorte que rien ne peut
jamais atteindre le rivage où s'échapper
dans la mer tout déversement serait une
catastrophe pour la région entière et
pour les baleines grises en particulier
chaque membre d'équipage est
parfaitement conscient du risque la
mission de sa madoff est terminée et il
reviendra dans un an
pendant ce temps le monitoring quotidien
se poursuivra comme c'est le cas depuis
le lancement de la plateforme en 2008
dans nos gisements pétroliers non loin
de nous il y a toujours un navire en
attente
spécialement conçu pour faire face aux
fuites
il dispose d'un équipement spécial à
bord qui collectent et élimine le
pétrole ils font partie de l'équipe
d'intervention d'urgence
il n'y a eu aucun incident dangereux
pour l'environnement sur cette
plateforme fou surtout d'autres
plateformes près de sakhaline
chaque entreprise opérant dans la région
soumet des rapports annuels sur son
activité et le wwf russie considère
qu'il s'agit là d'un travail exemplaire
de la part d'entreprises russes nous
essayons de nous assurer que nos
activités n'ont aucun impact négatif sur
les baleines grises et nous protégeons
également l'environnement des baleines
grises
nous évitons donc de voyager à grande
vitesse à travers les zones où elles se
nourrissent et où elles se déplacent
strikes nous faisons ainsi pour éviter
d'assommer les baleines car un tel
incident en mer peut être très dangereux
pour l'animal nous essayons également
d'éviter de produire trop de bruit dans
la zone où elles se nourrissent
bonjour bonjour ça va bien ça va
le voyage s'est bien passé ça va me ne
fait pas beau beaucoup de ventes chuter
oui merci
avant de donner un cours sur la nature à
l'école de nekrassov qu'à l'ére vinh
kalinin a visité l'un des postes
d'observation depuis lesquelles les
baleines sont surveillés à l'aide de
caméras infrarouges ses moyens
aujourd'hui deux baleines sont passés
wawel où elles ont nagé près de la côte
un long moment
les deux sites étaient en hausse à une
mère et son petit mais deux jeunes keita
et remporté 15 jeux comme consigne et
moi je vais vous montrer ce qu'on a pu
filmer des caméras sur lui mais tout va
bien oui bien sûr
sergueï tioulevine dirige l'équipe de
surveillance terrestre par infrarouge
qui dispose d'un équipement lui
permettant de voir les baleines même
dans l'obscurité
à condition qu'il n'y ait pas de
brouillard voilà une baleine qui nage
dans les vagues vous voyez région
intéressant elle n'a sur le flanc c'est
eux qui sort de l'eau montrent qu'elle
n'assure le flambeau compris à environ
20 mètres de la côte
on profite elle tourne en rond dans les
vagues elle joue pas ce sont surtout les
jeunes qui aiment barboter dans les
vagues
s'amuse bon c'est peut-être qu'ils ont
c'est comme du surf system encore une
grâce à ce système il est possible de
faire des observations la nuit sont
asphyxiés route que ce système film sans
problème des baleines que nous ne
pouvons pas voir au crépuscule problème
comme vous le voyez le g est très claire
on le distingue bien avec la mer sombre
tour
les caméras infrarouges sont installés
depuis trois ans les tendances locales
démarrer impliquait que les modules de
l'appareil de forage devait être
remorqué la nuit quand la marraine était
pas trop forte les caméras infrarouges
ont aidé à éviter qu'elle n'entre en
collision avec les baleines dans
l'obscurité
une fois l'opération terminée les
caméras sont restés pour la recherche
au fil des ans nous avons vu les
baleines revenir ici 14 il ya maintenant
plus de baleines la population augmenter
d'environ 3 4%
il nous semble que nos plateformes et la
population de baleines grises coexistent
parfaitement cela prouve que nous ne
faisons aucun mal le budget a augmenté
au cours des 15 dernières années pour
atteindre plusieurs millions de dollars
le projet de conservation de sakhaline a
peut être fait des baleines grises les
mammifères marins les plus étudiés de la
planète
faut voir tout en rose mais parfois en
cherchant à augmenter ses profits
l'entreprise propose des solutions que
les écologistes trouve dangereuse
une fois ils ont par exemple dit qu'il
était nécessaire de construire une autre
plateforme de forage tout près d'une
zone où les baleines grises mange une
autre panel et la communauté
environnementale ont rejeté cette idée
sur la jugeant trop dangereuse de la
gêne et marca sachs a tâté at il juste
après la société a finalement accepté
votre pseudo et il a trouvé un moyen de
forêt horizontalement pour atteindre les
couches situe à une certaine distance
des plateformes et des leçons d'alénya
ce match no5 trois fois
le cours est terminée et erwin veut que
les enfants se souviennent des noms des
animaux proches de l'extinction cygnes
chanteurs aigles de mer et léopard de
l'amour porte muscles de sibérie glouton
baleines grises ty men les baleines
grises qui se rendent à sakhaline chaque
année ne sont qu'une parmi un million
d'autres espèces au bord de l'extinction
la plateforme intergouvernementale
scientifique et politique sur la
biodiversité et les services
écosystémiques a prévenu qu'un huitième
de tous les animaux et plantes de la
planète risquait de disparaître dans un
avenir proche
ce scénario tragique a de fortes chances
de se réaliser
de nombreux animaux et plantes
disparaîtront des océans des lacs et des
rivières des forêts et des jungles des
plaines et des déserts des livres seront
écrits et des films réalisés en leur
mémoire mais il sera trop tard pour
changer le cours des choses
les écosystèmes se dégradent plus
rapidement qu'à aucun autre moment de
l'histoire de la terre pourtant nous
devons encore garder espoir des miracles
peuvent avoir lieu comme avec le retour
des baleines grises mais c'est un
million d'espèces qui ont besoin de
notre aide et l'histoire de la baleine
grise ni littéralement qu'une goutte
dans l'océan